sans caddie avec le bilan de l'année
2018 pour il est là c'est le cluster de
tourisme en martinique bonjour philippe
lécuyer bonjour merci de me recevoir
vous êtes donc le président de ce
cluster mais d'abord une réaction à
cette nouvelle diffusée sur nos antennes
dès hier matin la norvégienne s'est
finie la compagnie aérienne norvégienne
low cost avec des vols vers les états
unis
depuis les etats-unis et le canada vers
pointe à pitre et fort de france ce
n'est pas rentable
une réaction alors malheureusement on a
eu cette cette annonce hier une réaction
wind déjà c'est bien dommage alors je
suis pas sûr que le canada soit concerné
semblerait que ce soit pour l'instant
les états unis parce que la ligne
canadienne semble plus porteuse que
que ce qu'on avait sur les états unis la
difficulté c'est que ça fait quatre ans
que cette compagnie nous amène des
touristes mais on a du mal à voir les
chiffres notamment sur les le nombre de
martiniquais qui est rempli ses avions
et je rappelle que ses avions étaient là
à la mauvaise saison pour la clientèle
martiniquaise qui n'avait pas envie
d'aller forcément prendre un coup de
froid
oui avec des températures de - 40 des
répertoires c'était difficile en tout
cas les dirigeants de la norvège elles
nous ont dit très clairement que la
desserte depuis fort de france et pointe
à pitre ce sera fini et que la saison
prochaine et ben on verra par la suite
ce qui sort ce qui se passera puisque la
norvégienne doit faire des économies à
hauteur de 200 millions alors
conséquence cette clientèle
nord-américaine du canada des états unis
il faudra aller la capter autrement est
ce que c'est possible ça alors on avait
déjà un peu de clientèle avec les
rotations air france notamment
air canada et je sais plus transat qui
venait du canada aussi
il nous manque quand même les sièges
même si air france va retrouver son
monopole donc ces prix confortable il
faut absolument qu'on puisse trouver
une autre compagnie ou d'autres
compagnies qui accepte aussi de faire un
peu de low cost ça fait du bien au porte
monnaie tout le monde et ça fait venir
d'autres types de clientèle
expliquez-nous pourquoi sept marchés
importants cette clientèle nord
américaine
déjà le nombre d'américains et puis on
est une destination sud pour eux c c'est
intéressant de venir passer quelques
jours au soleil quand il justement vous
avez vu philippe lethuillier ils veulent
bien venir mais lorsque les avions
repartent à vide ça ne fonctionne pas
mais bien sûr faut que faut que ligne il
faut qu'elle fonctionne dans les deux
sens un peu c'est un peu la difficulté
de ces lignes low cost à certaines
saisons c'est tout le problème de la
saison passée la journée pourquoi
s'obstiner sachant que jamais depuis la
carie vers le nord c'est peut-être ça ne
fonctionne pas bah ça à nous après de
faire des efforts pour que ça fonctionne
soit en subventionnant un peu plus les
compagnies libyennes ou comme ça se
faisait par le passé je sais que
l'europe même pas beaucoup ça mais ça
pourrait être un moyen d'attirer de la
clientèle on a besoin de cette clientèle
américaine même si on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure on n'a pas
beaucoup de d'américains dans les hôtels
de notre groupe mais mais on en a besoin
c'est indéniable alors le cluster du
tourisme un marché dont vous êtes le
président fier d'eux tire un bilan 2018
les chiffres stade toujours autour de
65% d'une clientèle hexagonale chez nous
27 28 % d'antilles guyane est ce sont
des chiffres qui ne bouge pas oui c'est
à peu près constant même le taux
d'occupation global à l'année entre 60
et 65%
et puis danser 65% se rend compte
effectivement que la clientèle
hexagonale
produit 65 % de nuitées que la
martinique 24 un peu plus de 24 % de
nuitées la guadeloupe un petit peu de 12
2% ce qui fait qu'on a une clientèle
française à 90% alors ce cluster de
tourisme je ne sais pas c'est pas
seulement que les hôtels
il ya aussi les loueurs de voitures y a
il ya plein d'autres partenaires qui
vous permet d'avoir une vision très très
parfaite de la situation alors peut-être
pas parfaite mais effectivement ça fait
quelques années qu'on sait et
constituant gloucester donc c'est une
grappe d'entreprises il ya 85
entreprises du monde du tourisme
alors certes on a des hôteliers mais
aussi d'autres types d'hébergement
loueurs de meublés comme les gîtes de
france ou d'autres sociétés des loueurs
de voitures des agences de voyages des
lieux de visite des taxis des
transporteurs ce qui permet d'avoir une
vision globale et commune de
des stratégies qu'il faudrait mettre en
place en martinique alors pourquoi
demander par exemple que les chiffres
soient peaufiner vous semblez dire que
les données qui peuvent paraître par ci
par là notamment avec le comité
martiniquais du tourisme sont pas
toujours fiables vous aimeriez peaufiner
ses de ces données comme par exemple
alors il le cnt a mis un observatoire
qui s'alimentent d'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs dont il est acquis fourni
des chiffres pour l'hôtellerie et puis à
la la ça mc qui pour l'aéroport fournit
des statistiques mais on reste sur sur
les chiffres globaux on n'arrive pas à
voir pour une destination comme new york
par exemple qui nous interpelle
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais pu avoir le
nombre de passagers dans le sens new
york fort de france et dans l'autre sens
fort-de-france new york donc on a du mal
à savoir s'il faut aider une destination
parce qu'on n'a pas la connaissance de
ces chiffres
autre interpellation vous dites qu'il ya
quand même des nord américains qui
viennent ici mais on ne sait pas
exactement où ils vont dormir à toute la
page chez vous alors chez nous fin dans
notre dans le panel qui est que l'on
observe dans notre groupement on n'a que
1 5 % de nuitées qui sont réalisées par
des américains cette année faire en 2018
c'est pas beaucoup
ça représente 8000 8 500 personnes fin
nuitées c'est bien insuffisant et c'est
bien en dessous de nos espérances on
espérait en capter beaucoup plus alors
faut se rappeler que c'est souvent
décider ces jours très court les
américains ayant peu de vacances et
qu'ils choisissent peut-être d'autres
types d'hébergement que l'hôtel ils vont
sûrement en meublés de tourisme en ville
là etc
mais là aussi on manque cruellement de
statistiques précises sur sur ces points
là qu'une des questions qu'on a envie de
vous poser ce matin à propos de notre de
notre offre hôtelière est ce qu'il y a
moyen de la quantifier
que ce soit qualitativement que ce soit
en nombre d'établissements est ce que
nous sommes capables de faire face aux
réalités du marché touristique
aujourd'hui
alors on le fait quelques mois de
l'année en haute saison pourrait avoir
je pense 200 chambres de plus on
arriverait sûrement aller remplir en
haute saison
malheureusement la basse saison arrivant
on est tous en perte de vitesse et on
aurait trop de trop de chambre si si on
construisait des hôtels vous ce qui va
arriver on en prendra peut-être toute à
l'heure de toute façon je crois qu'il
faut on a un parc qui est un peu
vieillissant même vieillissant il faut
absolument qu'on rénove petit à petit
pour être non seulement en terme de deux
d'image destination c'est important mais
aussi en qualité de la prestation qu'on
peut offrir à nos visiteurs
on a arrêté l'hémorragie et de cette
fermeture d'hôtel la semaine dernière
vous semblez dire que du projet existe
que certains pourraient sortir de
terrasser rapidement fait le petit topo
de la situation alors il ya déjà la
reprise des établissements qui ont cessé
leur activité il ya quelques années le
club marouba au carbet des gens se
positionnerait actuellement pour
reprendre ces établissements pareil pour
le club des trois ils n ont qu à
l'insalan ou là
un petit groupe martinique aux canadiens
seraient aussi en face de reprendre le
diamant drogue qu'on a toujours la scène
sa marque y est positionné mais on n'a
pas beaucoup de nouvelles ça nous
inquiète un petit peu leur ces méridiens
toujours l'ancien méridien à icare a
annoncé qu'il jetait l'épongé à quelques
jours donc faut tout reprendre à zéro la
mairie détroit dirait des trois ilets va
le faire je pense rapidement mais ces
cds projets qui vont prendre encore
quelques quelques paire d'années il
faudrait peut-être aborder cette
question de la définition de notre
destination la martinique sé crois
exactement c'est une station balnéaire
c'est une station on peut faire du
spirit ory du suivi tourisme c'est une
station qui permet de se reposer alain
minc c'est quoi exactement l'impression
quand on a des difficultés à positionner
la martinique et c'est peut-être là que
le bât blesse
alors c'est vrai quand on interroge nos
visiteurs nos touristes y viennent
essentiellement voeux pour le balnéaire
à 65%
donc pour la plage
par contre nous on n'a pas réussi à
avoir une stratégie commune sur ce qu'on
voulait faire de fin qui on voulait
accueillir
donc on fait un peu tout qui doit faire
sa ba c'est la mission du cmt de la ctm
d'avoir une stratégie précise comme
saint barth à une stratégie extrêmement
claires et précises pour une certain
type de clientèle
même si ça reste du balnéaire ils ont
décidé d'avoir du balnéaire chic
oui parce que le balnéaire il faudrait
peut-être et regarder à plusieurs
reprises
vous savez qu'on attend une vague
d'algues sargasses de façon massive à
partir du mois d'avril
est ce que ce ne risque pas d'être tout
simplement de signer notre arrêt de mort
si on ne bat s'y rend on ne compte que
sur le balnéaire
alors faut il ya déjà le problème des
sargasses qui est un phénomène important
mais qui reste un épiphénomène
au vu de ce qu'attend le monde dans les
années qui viennent il ya aussi la
diminution de nos plages et peut-être la
montée des eaux qui va aussi perturber
grandement le tourisme balnéaire
puisqu'il y aura plus de plage merci
philippe lécuyer d'abriter avec nous
rappelle que vous êtes président du
cluster de tourisme en martinique et
président de ea lire merci merci et
bonne journée